bonsoir nous sommes le 26 novembre il
est 18h nous sommes en direct pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 lactu le journal
de la rédaction voici les principaux
titres que nous allons développer le
dossier de l'école bisé à senscir qui
divise les responsables politiques elle
ne sera pas rasée mais finalement
rénovée plus plus que les choix opérés
c'est la méthode que dénonce
l'opposition l'association du fun pour
tous qui depuis guuy encouragit pour
favoriser les rencontres entre personnes
handicapées et valides évoque des
difficultés financières elle voit son
avenir s'assombrir l'hiver approche mais
pas encore la neige pour autant les
services techniques des différentes
villes se préparent Murielle Bti
directrice des infrastructures de la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans en
yelin sera en plateau pour nous en dire
plus au cours de ce journal on passe
tout d'abord à l'image du jour avec avec
Pôle emploi en Île-de-France qui
organise jusqu'au 29 novembre les
rendez-vous de l'emploi dans les agences
de la région des job dating sont
proposés aujourd'hui c'était au tour de
l'agence de Guy encour de mettre en
relation employeurs et demandeurs
d'emploi 10 employeurs qui ont reçu 84
demandeurs d'emploi présélectionnés pour
des postes majoritairement accès sur le
commerce le directeur de l'agence nous
explique l'intérêt d'une telle opération
alors c'est vrai qu'on avait tendance
les autres années à faire des des
promotions des pour emploi à l'extérieur
là on a préféré privilégier faire une
opération mais à l'intérieur d'une
agence aussi pour permettre aux
employeurs bah de découvrir aussi la la
l'agence voilà une agence n'est pas
réservée qu'emandeur d'emploi elle est
aussi elle est aussi pour les employeurs
donc ça nous permet aussi de montrer
notre offre de service aux employeurs on
a fait une recherche de de demandeurs
d'emplois on les a donc contacté par
téléphone on a fait des petits
entretiens au téléphone euh VO leur
motivation et tout ça pour vraiment
mettre des profils euh appropriés par
rapport à ce type de
recrutement d'autres job dating de ce
type donc seront organisés début 2014
rénové mais pas rasé la décision est
enfin prise pour l'école bizè c'est à
saint-cir d'audit en rapport
d'architecte de la conclusion et que la
structure du bâtiment peut finalement
être saine et rester en place si tout
suit son cours le chantier pourrait
démarrer en
2015 l'école bisé à sincir l'école ne
sera pas rasé mais rénové les
discussions et les rapports d'expertise
ont été nombreux finalement la décision
a été prise de réhabiliter on a demandé
à un deuxième cabinet
d'architecte parce que le projet
du on appellerait ça un architecte
programmiste
euh me plaisait pas du tout il y avait
une rue qui traversait le soquir euh
pour faire financer ça par la commune il
construisait des bâtiments d'habitation
en bordure de la du boulevard donc on a
demandé un autre cabin architecte de
nous donner sa version et nous a dit
mais le la structure du bâtiment est
saine on peut la conserver donc on va la
conserver voilà à quoi pourrait
ressembler la nouvelle école bisée pour
leur ce n'est qu'une esquisse un
concours d'architecte va être lancé en
attendant le choix de la rénovation ne
déplaî pas au maire loin de là ça m'a
enlevé une énorme épine du pied parce
que bon c'était quand même un bâtiment
le fait de le
démolir avec les coups de
démolition de le
reconstruire finalement le fait de faire
la réhabilitation il y a pas une grosse
différence la facture totale sélévé à 10
millions d'euros en bordure de l'école
un petit bâtiment accueille un centre de
loisirs lui sera rasé et est reconstruit
en plus grand si tout suit son cours
concours d'architecte et appel d'offre
le chantier pourrait se lancer en 2015
sur un terrain à tenant qu alge pourrait
être installé pour accueillir
provisoirement les élèves pour
l'opposition la rénovation est une bonne
idée mais c'est la méthode qui ne va pas
on peut pas expliquer aux saint-syriens
en 2009 que la réhabilitation coûte 1
million d'euros pour mieux leur dire en
2011 que la réhabilitation elle est pas
faisable qu'il faut détruire l'école
qu'il faut euh vendre le foncier pour
financer pour mieux dire 7 ou 8 mois
après que non vraiment la réhabilitation
est la meilleure solution l'école bisé
est l'une des anciennes écoles de
saint-cir l'école la commune compte 10
groupes
scolaires toujours saint-cir politique
face au mère sortant Bernard Debin UMP
gaïane des jardins sans étiquette et
désormais candidate au municipal 2014
pour lancer sa campagne l'élu
aujourd'hui d'opposition fait du porte à
porte avec son équipe quasiment
quotidiennement Anthony Resche Olivier
moine l'ont
suivi à moins de 4 mois du premier tour
Gaetane des jardins se mettent en ordre
de marche présente sur la liste de
Daniel Farnier en 2008 face au ma
sortant la saint-syienne se lance à la
course de la mairie en 2014 pour se
faire connaître des habitants la
candidate sans étiquette politique fait
du porte à porte je laisse un
petit merci de votre visite merci à
vousevoir
monsieurir de manière générale sont de
très bons échanges enfin moi j'en suis
ravi finalement je n'étais pas rompu à
cet exercice mais j'aime ça je peux le
dire j'aime ça les contacts sont
enrichissants sont
francs quelquefois
bien pimenté c'est pas le cas mais les
gens sont vraiment intéressés il y a un
bon échange d'idées Gaetane des jardins
fustige le manque d'équipement sportif
et de structure pouvant accueillir les
personnes âgées l'élu d'opposition
critique également l'absence de cohésion
de l'équipe municipale et la gestion
économique du maire actuel 10 millions
d'euros seraient inutilisé c'est pas un
bilan
catastrophique mais ce n'est pas un
bilan qui me convient à partir du moment
où les saint-cériens manquent de tout et
en plus ils ne sont pas écoutés enfin
d'ailleurs le maire n'écoute personne
donc ça je ne supporte pas mais quant à
savoir les grandes lignes de son
programme les saint-ciriens devront
faire preuve de patience pour l'instant
la liste de Gaitan des jardins reste
encore
ouverte la fédération ivelinoise du
Secours populaire français qui annonce
avoir reversé 8000 € suite au passage du
typhon sur les Philippines dans la nuit
du 8 au 9 novembre dernier l'association
travaille sur place avec la Fondation
Renata basée à Jakarta des kits de
première nécessité ont été distribués le
bilan provisoire de cette catastrophe
fait état de plus de 13 millions de
personnes affectées dont 5 millions
d'enfants vous pouvez encore faire vos
dons financiers à l'adresse qui
s'affiche du fun pour tous c'est un
centre de loisirs en inclusion
collective une association basée à Guill
encour crée en 2005 qui accueille des
enfants souffrant de déficience mentales
mais qui doit faire face aujourd'hui à
d'importants problème budgétairees à tel
point d'envisager maintenant de mettre
tout simplement la clé sous la porte
état des lieux avec Anthony Resche et
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude les couloirs
de cette association pourrai rester
désespérément vides pourtant depuis mars
2005 du fun pour tous s'occupe d'enfants
de 5 à 17 ans souffrant de déficience
mental et propose un mode de garde
unique dans le départ
pour les familles dont les enfants ne
peuvent pas ou plus être accueill dans
les structures de loisir classiqu mais
pour terminer l'année l'association doit
faire face à un manque de 50000 € le
directeur Bruno grevallet a dû se faire
licencier je ne suis plus salarié de
l'association j'ai j'ai demandé j'ai
fait une demande à la direction
départementale du travail pour que mon
personnel soit mis en chômage partiel
pour éviter les licenciers
justement donc on va attendre on va
mettre voilà le on va se mettre en
service minimum on va dire pour
continuer à accueillir les enfants quand
même et proposer des solutions au
familles mais en service minimum donc on
va réduire les temps d'accueil pour
éviter justement bah de fermer de par
son caractère atypique le centre n'est
pas considéré comme une structure
médico-sociale Bruno grevalet espère
toujours voir son association être
déclaré comme innovante dans le cadre de
la loi de 2006 sur l'égalité des chances
ce qui lui permettrait d'obtenir un
financement de la part de l'agence
régionale de santé on est sur plusieurs
champs et en même temps on est sur aucun
champ à chaque fois moi quand je fais
des demandes de financement ou quand je
R des personnes publiques ou politiqu
elles me disent oui mais vous rentrez
pas dans les cases en fait vous êtes
voilà un dispositif atypique et on peut
pas vous mettre dans une case du coup il
faudrait créer une case en fait qui nous
corresponde l'association est également
en attente de 20000 € d'un payé de la
part des parents qui ne peuvent pas tous
assumer le coût financier du centre en
2012 du fun pour tous a accueilli 84
enfants issus de 25 communes des
ivelines malgré les difficultés Bruno
Grosvalet ne manque pas de projet il
souhaiterait a créé un accueil enfant
par an pour les 0,5 ans en
2014 les Yvelines comptent plus de 18200
établissements commerciaux et donc
autant de beaux commerciaux ce sont ces
contrats entre un bailleur et un
locataire qui ont leur spécificité pour
mieux l'expliquer une conférence vient
d'avoir lieu sur le thème elle a été
proposée par la Maison de l'Entreprise
de C qutin en nivel beau à loué des
panneaux que l'on peut croiser dans
l'agglomération cinquantinoise le bail
commercial une proposition
d'investissement qui peut séduire mais
il faut bien connaître les contours il y
a vraiment sa particularité comparé à un
bail d'habitation au profil d'un
particulier en ce sens que le locataire
va bénéficier d'un statut protecteur il
y a une durée qui est de 9 ans qui se
décompose en trois périodes et on
l'intitule traditionellement 3 6 9 pour
le baayur c'est également un schéma qui
est très intéressant puisque lui il va
compter sur un locataire qui va rester
longtemps et qui va effectivement
théoriquement lui verser des loyers des
charges qui va pouvoir indexer au fur et
à mesure de l'évolution de la
conjoncture autre protection si le
locataire manque à ses obligations le
bailleur peut entraîner une action
judiciaire pour demander la résiliation
du bail la procédure est rapide environ
4 mois un marché spécifique avec des
pièges à éviter oui il y a des pièges
qui sont vraiment très important et qui
ont trait notamment bah à la durée
précisément et surtout aux charges et
conditions du bail et particulièrement
les clauses qui concernent les travaux
les charges subies par le locataire euh
les bailleurs ont parfois tendance à
vouloir imposer davantage de charges
financières à leur locataires euh voilà
donc les locataires ont très intérêt à
négocier ces clauses-là ou encore les
clauses qui vont avoir àrait comment
dire aux travaux qui vont devoir
supporter en fin de bail de remise en
état voilà euh côté bailleur il y a des
subtilités à évidemment à mettre en
place aussi qui sont davantage liés aux
garanties euh du locataire les garanties
financières attention donc aux clauses
c'est essentiel car en général quand un
bail est signé on ne revient pas dessus
la location qu'elle soit résidentielle
ou qu'elle soit commerciale elle est
très complexe et c'est une erreur de
penser que c'est quelque chose qui
s'invente le conseil est vraiment
nécessaire ou alors faut être
autodidacte et puis former soimême mais
c'est vrai que ça s'improvise pas
franchement invité du journal de ce soir
Muriel bâti bonsoir vous êtes la
directrice des infrastructures pour la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yveline dans un mois ce sera l'hiver ce
n'est pas un scoop la neige n'est pas
encore là et vous avez activé tout de
même le plan hiver le 15 novembre à plan
actif jusqu'au 31 mars comment se
présente ce dispositif quelles en sont
les grandes lignes alors grandes lignes
déjà des moyens des moyens humains et
des moyens techniques une équipe
d'astrint hivernal pour la communauté
d'agglomération en collaboration avec
les bien sûr les équipes des villes et
puis un prestataire un prestataire
extérieur qui intervient pour nous neuf
salleuses euh pour faire les 200 km de
voie qui concerne un comité
d'agglomération l'obj objectif c'est de
permettre la circulation une circulation
optimale même si la neige est là même si
le ver glas est là alors dans des
conditions je dirais normal hors crise
alerte rougeentellement préfectoral bien
entendu même si effectivement on utilise
toujours les moyens dans ces cas-là mais
effectivement c'est pouvoir assurer la
sécurité de façon journalière dès qu'il
y a glissance ou neige pour les usagers
de la route et puis dans toutes les
conditions bien entendu de pouvoir
assurer un minimum de sécurité sur des
itinéraires euh défin à plusieurs
niveaux on a des itinéraires
prioritaires d'autres qui le sont plus
secondaires en fonction du trafic
concernés et les automobilistes peuvent
être au courant quasiment en temps réel
de la situation il y a des SMS qui leur
sont envoyés pour pe qu'ils s'inscrivent
sur le site internet de l'agglomération
tout à fait donc là ben on invite bien
sûr la population à venir s'inscrire ça
leur permettra de savoir effectivement
si nos saleuses sont en fonctionnement
où vont sortir ça veut dire ça permet de
savoir s'il y a un phénomène météo qui
arrive n'hésitez pas noubliez pas vous
pouve vouscrire sur l'adresse voilà qui
s'est affiché le site de l'agglomération
de de saquentin parmi les différentes
choses qui existent qui sont mis en
place aussi cette année j'ai pu voir
qu'il y avait des bacs qui seraient en
libre accès sur certains points plus ou
moins difficiles les automobilistes vont
pouvoir descendre de la voiture et
mettre un petit peu de sel si jamais ils
sont bloqués c'est en prévision de
vraiment d'une crise avérée c'està-dire
quand le préventif
ne ne sert plus même si les saluses
continuent à fonctionner pour que les
gens qui sont en panne qui vont que leur
voiture glisse n'arrivent plus à avancer
puissent mettre effectivement mélange
selle sable pour pouvoir s'en sortir
bien sû souvent avec l'aide des autres
véhicules qui sont coinés derri l'entide
qui à ce momentl ça c'est donc les
points sensibles c'est sur les points
sensibles qu'on va mettre c'estes
prépositionn ces bac àell ça ne va pas
remplacer les salleuses bien sûr que non
non c'est pour vraiment pctuellement
pouvoir aider en fait l'usager de la
route qui qui est coincé et qui qui
n'arrive plus à démarrer en fait les
saleuses que l'on peut suivre en temps
réel vous les avez équipé de GPS cette
année oui alors c'est également une
nouveuté pour cette année des GPS qui
vont être sur les les neuf saveules pour
savoir les itinéraires également des
celleuses vérifier que la prestation est
bien faite mais également à terme
pouvoir aussi dévier si nécessaire les
salleuses en cas de besoin en
s'apercevant par exemple qu'un
tinitéraire a plus besoin qu'un autre ou
en cas de crise de pouvoir les les faire
évoluer sur le le les itinéraires de la
commité d'agglomération voir sur
l'itinéraire de des communes alors ne
vous inquiétez pas si vous nous suivez
en direct la neige n'est pas tombée sur
51 aujourd'hui ce sont bien évidemment
les images de l'année précédente et à
chaque fois c'est une bouillie de de
selle qui est répandue hein c'est ça
hein tout à fait alors c'est c'est un
procédé comme on avait pu préciser
l'année dernière qui mélange sel et
Saumur qui permet d'intervenir dans des
conditions météo même très basse c'estàd
des températures très basses donc une
plus grande efficacité et puis pour le
développement durable meilleure
puisqu'on dépense 30 % de moins de sel
alors qui déclenche l'intervention là on
a vu le dispositif qui était mis en
place et si jamais il y a une alerte qui
qui qui arrive comment ça fonctionne qui
déclenche il y a des agents d'astreintes
c'est Al vaille météo soit dans la
journée par le service voir exploitation
ou par les agendasastreintes la nuit ou
le weekend veille météo veille terrain
également patrouille sur le terrain
coordination avec les services des
villes des communes de l'agglomération
pour analyser effectivement le phénomène
et dire s'il est nécessaire ou non de
sortir et puis ensuite nous on enclenche
la sortie auprès du prestataire et puis
auprès de notre régie puisque nous avons
également une régie qui intervient sur
les espaces publics notamment autour des
gares et puis sur certains cheminements
qui n'ont pas de Rivin direct c'est un
gros dispositif ça coûte combien quel
est le budget chaque année alors ça
dépend des années hein déjà il y a un
forfait d'astreinte puis qu'il faut que
l'entreprise soit présente avec ses
salleuses qui est autour de 500000 € et
puis après chaque sortie c'est entre 11
et 15000 € en fonction de l'itinéraire
moins il neige mieux c'est pour les
finances l'agglomération c'est mie fin
oui et puis je pense que pour les
usagers aussi environ 200 km de route
géré par la Communauté d'Agglomération
alors on le rappelle encore et chaque
année hein forcément toutes les routes
ne sont pas gérées par l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin une partie des routes
sont gérées par les communes donc une
partie par l'agglomération une partie
par le Département une partie par la
région comment ça se ça se différencie
sur le terrain je pense que sur le
terrain je dirais pour pour tout le
monde ça ne se différencie pas
effectivement par contre qu fois parce
que telle ou telle route n'est pas n'est
pas forcément déigé mais ça ne dépend
pas du même interlocut donc les routes
départementales et bien c'est le
département les routes nationales c'est
l'état donc qu'on appelle la Drif et
puis a les voiries communales ce sont
les communes et puis les voiries
intercommunales ce sont effectivement
c'est la casqu qui intervient pour la
communauté d'agglomération c'est 200 km
se trou voilà ce sont les voies
principales je dirais où les plus forts
trafic circulent h mais sachant
qu'aujourd'hui la distinction vu qu'on
se se concerte pour pouvoir traiter les
voies la distinction elle se voit
beaucoup moins entre la voirie
communales et les comités d'agloot il y
a vraiment une gestion commune en fait
de l'intervention là on est sur le
dispositif on va dire classique un
dispositif spécial si jamais il y avait
une crise importante comme il y a pu
avoir il y a quelques années où là tous
les automobilistes étaient bloqués sur
sur les routes il a fallu ouvrir des
gymnases par exemple alors déjà je pense
que en préventif c'est en préventif
qu'il faut faut frapper le plus fort
même et juste veiller au niveau de la
météo pour savoir ce qui va se passer
sur les phénomènes justement qui
pourraient être beaucoup plus graves et
puis s'organiser par rapport à ça en
amont ensuite on a les outils hein on
est quand même on a les outils humains
on a les
outils matériels pour pouvoir intervenir
on a cette coordinisation très forte
aujourd'hui qui se joue avec les
communes le conseil général et les
services de l'État pour pouvoir vraiment
une action coordonnée et je pense que
cette communication et cette
coordination permet également de bien
traiter le problème alors après il faut
être clair une crise 10 15 cm en plein
lundi après-midi à la sortie ça sera
compliqué ça restera compliqué puisqueen
fait les voitures bloque le système déjà
les saleuses ne peuvent plus passer
justement on va faire une petite pause
nous sommes allés aujourd'hui vous poser
cette question équipez-vous vos
véhicules pour pour la neige pour
faciliter la circulation si jamais
c'était nécessaire voici quelques
réponses non et pourquoi parce que pour
de TR jours de neige par an ici ça a
aucun intérêt donc je vais pas acheter
quatre pneus neige donc je je me
servirai jamais ouais non pas
particulièrement parce que je l'utilise
très peu l'hiver la dernière non non je
l'équipais pas cétait un 44 donc j'avais
pas utilité par rapport à la neige bah
tout dépend oui on déjà les pneus neiges
au moins oui des pneus neiges non pas du
tout non non mais non elle couche dehors
malheureusement donc effectivement je
fais rien c'est une petite voiture de
ville il y a pas besoin de PNE neige
dans nos régions moi je neéquipe pas
pour l'iver pour 15 jours de neige
j'estimee que c'est pas vraiment très
rentable alors tout de même aussi
rappeler qu'en marche de ce plan qui a
été mis en place par l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin il est important que
chacun des usagers ait une bonne
conduite plus que jamais sur la route on
évite de prendre sa voiture si jamais on
sait qu'il y a une alerte météo
transport en commun aussi ce sont les
les bons réflexes à avoir bah transport
en commun je pense effectivement nos
itinéraires et je dirais notre mode de
travail de prestation on oriente de
manière à pouvoir libérer les voies les
plus fortement emprunté par les
transports en commun donc effectivement
il est préférable de d'emprunter les
transports en commun dans ce cas-là on
parlait des routes on parle transport
commun est-ce que les trottoirs aussi
font partie des priorités de de
l'agglomération pour éviter les
mauvaises chutes alors peut-être un
petit rappel déjà la population doit
nettoyer le le bord de son trottoir
maintenant il y a effectivement des
trottoirs auquels il n'y a pas de
Riverin où le justement la communaité
d'agglomération organise le traitement
on gère autour des gares puisque c'est
les zones les plus fortes justement en
terme d'usager piéton de manière à ce
qu'il puivent rentrer et sortir des
gares et après les itinéraires
principaux merci d'être venu nous
préciser Pr h ce plan hivernal pour la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans
vous êtes prévenu on espère un hiver
sans stress pour les usagers l'an
dernier 42 sorties de saluse pour
l'agglomération ont été recensé la
plupart du temps c'était à titre
préventif nous poursuivons le journal
avec ce weekend un stage d'ikido qui
était organisé au dojo du gymnase les
pyramides à voisin le Bretonneux
l'objectif découvrir un art martial
méconnu et pourtant abordable le
reportage d'Olivier Maniscalco et
d'Antony créé en 1931 par le japonais
Morie ushiba l'ikido arrive en France
dans les années 50 dans cette martiale à
la différence du karaté ou du judo le
but n'est pas de combattre son
adversaire mais au contraire de guider
son agression pour l'annuler en pratique
l'attaquant appelé yuke va tenter de
porter un coup au défenseur le Tori ce
dernier va uniquement contrôler
l'agression en se servant de l'énergie
de l'attaquant sans jamais riposter et
avec ce principe de non opposition
l'ikido est véritablement ouvert à tout
type de public de 6 ans jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie
c'est un sport où on demande pas de
force il y a pas de comme il y a pas
deopposition même si quelqu'un moi j'ai
des élèves qui font plus de 100 kg et
j'ai des élèves femmes qui font 45 kg
elles peuvent se permettre de projeter
parce que elles vont aller dans le même
sens que cette agression disons 100 kg
plus 45 ça fait 145 kg
qui har intense mais non brutale laikido
permet l'entretien du corps chez les
seiors la souplesse et l'énergie qu'il
requier est aussi particulièrement
adapté aux femmes des femmes chez qui
laikido peut permettre de se sentir plus
forte en cas d'agression ça permet
d'avoir une attitude vis-à-vis de des
relations extérieures difficiles d'être
beaucoup mieux posé dans dans ses dans
son corps et de ne pas avoir peur
inutilement parce qu'en fait c'est
souvent la situation de peur de stress
qui permet l'agression et donc si on est
solide de face à l'adversaire ENF face à
l'agresseur ça lui change un petit peu
son processus mental et interroge donc
il part attaquer ou faire quelque chose
aussi facilement si vous souhaitez
pratiquer l'ikido les inscriptions sont
toujours ouverte au club de voisin le
Bretonneux mais avant de devenir un Yuk
ou un Tor et de revêtir la jupe noire le
Akama vous pouvez assister à un cours
gratuitement et poser vos questions aux
professeur avant de faire votre
choix et on se termine avec des images
qui vont vous ouvrir l'appétit si vous
nous suivez en direct ce soir le trophée
de la veine lancé par l'association des
tocs françaises voici 10 ans et dont
nous parlions hier avec son président du
jury cette année Thierry mars a livré
son verdict Bruno Bolmont chef chez
daloyot l'emporte après 5h30 d'épreuve
et face à CIN autres candidats ce
trophée est considéré comme
l'antichambre du concours des Meilleurs
Ouvriers de France il est considéré
comme une référence en France et se
déroule dans les cuisines de teekoma à
joui en Josas tiierry Mark c'était donc
le président du jury le chef étoilé si
vous n'étiez pas avec nous au début de
cette édition on revoit à présent
l'image du jour Paul emploi en
Île-de-France qui organise jusqu'au 29
novembre des rendez-vous de l'emploi
dans toutes les agences de la région des
job dating proposé aujourd'hui c'était à
guillancour mise en relation avec les
employeurs et les demandeurs d'emploi 10
employeurs qui ont reçu 84 demandeurs
d'emploi présélectionnés pour des postes
majoritairement aés sur le commerce le
directeur de l'agence nous explique
l'intérêt d'une telle opération alors
c'est vrai qu'on avait tendance les
autres années à faire des des promotions
des services emploi à l'extérieur là on
a préféré privilégier faire une
opération mais à l'intérieur d'une
agence aussi pour permettre aux
employeurs B de découvrir aussi la la
l'agence voilà une agence n'est pas
réservée C demandur d'emploi elle est
aussi elle est aussi pour les employeurs
donc ça nous permet aussi de montrer
notre offre de service aux employeurs on
a fait une recherche de de demandeur
d'emploi on les a donc contacté par
téléphone euh on a fait des petits
entretiens au téléphone voil motivation
et tout ça pour vraiment mettre des
profils appropriés par rapport à ce type
de
recrutement je vous retrouve demain en
direct à 18h pour une nouvelle édition
du 78 lactu et puis ce mardi soir je
vous retrouve aussi pour municipal 2014
le rendez-vous politique de la rédaction
il sera notamment question des campagnes
des candidats sur Rambouillet ou encore
et en cours excellente soirée sur notre
antenne